so who's my guest this week it's the
chief medical advisor to the u.s
president dr anthony fauci
from death threats to fouchy fever
if you become one of the biggest figures
of the coronavirus pandemic you're going
to elicit a reaction
[Music]
as a member of the white house covid
task force under president trump dr
fauci became the face of the u.s
scientific response
as the crisis continued science and
politics clashed his attempts to
understand the virus and save lives were
welcomed by many but derided as
authoritarian by others
some of his advice led to chants of fire
fouchy a slogan that was retweeted by
his boss in the oval office but he kept
his job
he says letting the science speak got
him into a little bit of trouble
so how does he see things now as the
wave of the pandemic retreats
and with a new president in the white
house here's what's coming up i chose
this and i accept the risks but my
family my wife and my children
continually get hassled and threatened
by things that are really unimaginable
are you relieved you don't have
president trump in that position anymore
back then it made it very uncomfortable
for me because i had to frankly disagree
publicly
with the president of the united states
dr fauci thank you so much for joining
me and i have to say i feel like i know
you because i have seen your face so
much even here in the uk over the last
couple of years how has it been for you
becoming so much of a household name
well i i don't really think of it at all
as being a household name more so that
we have to get
the correct evolving scientific
information out and that cinch it's such
a moving target
that really necessitates
you know rather frequent updating
of what the status is both from a public
health as well as from a scientific
standpoint so it's really a very unique
situation that
i and some of my colleagues find
ourselves in
is that it's not static
and when you have an event that occurs
and you brief
either domestically or internationally
and generally things don't change you
don't see very much
of a person but when you have a very
fluid
dynamic situation that we have right now
that
really creates an unprecedented
situation where i have become
very well known merely because of the
need to continually
update and brief
at both a domestic and international
level i mean to that point and and i
totally take that point
because of the nature of the situation
and i imagine at times it's been it's
been frightening you know how much it's
been changing and the reality on
people's lives
you know you must have felt enormous
pressure and i imagine you're also
receiving a lot of emails from people a
lot of people asking you what was going
on
are you able to look back at that now
and kind of take that in
no i still can't take it in because it's
completely transformed
my life in so many ways and you know
positive ways and negative ways because
of the charged nature
and the stress that this outbreak has
put
on my own country and throughout the
world
superimposed upon the divisive political
nature in my own country
there has been um
really
a great deal of of divisiveness and even
rancor
among people so that you have people who
look to you
many many people and i think the
majority
that look to the science look to me as
someone who is communicating
the science and the public health
in a way that's positive and productive
because they want to know
what's best for themselves and their
family and their community
and yet there are some
you know who really are swept up in
conspiracy theories and
distortions of reality and anti-science
untruths
that create a hostility towards me and
the scientific community in general that
really is unprecedented we've never seen
anything
like that where the only thing that i've
ever
expressed
that i everything that i've ever
communicated
has been based on
the reality and the evidence as we know
it and it does change the evidence
because there are things that we know
now
we're dealing with a virus that
continues to fool us it continues to
move
it continues to evolve it continues to
create
new variants in your country what do you
attribute that to that that lack of
trust among some
well it's become the politization of
what should be a purely public health
issue
the idea that we have in our country
the level of acceptance
of well-proven
public health
interventions
such as vaccines
which have clearly been shown to be
life-saving to be highly effective
and very safe
and very often it's a long
ideological lines when it should be
there should be no ideological
differences
in interpretation of what our core
immutable public health
principles and yet the pushback that we
have
against
seemingly obvious
and scientifically proven
public health principles is
extraordinary and the degree of rancor
is such that i never would have imagined
in my wildest dreams
that anything that i've ever said which
is purely public health and
non-political and non-ideologic
leads to continual death threats against
me to the point
where i have to be surrounded by
federal agents for my protection all the
time i mean that seems inconceivable
if you turn back the clock and talk
about
other public health crises that we've
had with polio and with measles and with
smallpox
and the things that we've had to alert
the public to
there's never been a situation where the
the divisiveness have led to
the threat of physical harm
that that is as unprecedented as
the notoriety that i have
regarding the purely communication of
public health principles how did you
cope with that how have you coped with
having death threats i mean are you
scared what about your family as well
well you know i mean i have a job and
i've devoted myself to my job i've been
at the nih now for more than 50 years
and i've been the director
of the institute the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases
for 38 years and i've served and advised
seven presidents going all the way back
to ronald reagan so this is my job i
understand it and
this is the life that i've chosen i
never would have imagined
that it would be be set with the kinds
of rancor and threats so i don't like it
my family i think is the one that i feel
uh more more concerned about because
i chose this and i accept the risks
but my family my wife and my children
continually get hassled and threatened
by things that are really unimaginable i
mean obscene phone calls and threats and
knowing their addresses and knowing
where they work and knowing
what they do and
to continually hassling them that is
just absolutely preposterous that that
goes on
in society i'm very sorry to hear that
you know i i really am because of of
course what you're doing at the same
time you know you're trying to save
lives and yet you're receiving death
threats i i understand it's different to
what has been before but who do you
blame for that
you know i don't think that one can just
pick out a person or a movement to blame
but what we do have is something that's
very disturbing
in this country is what i refer to
as the normalization of untruths there's
so much distortion
of reality and conspiracy theories
that are spread widely
by social media
where you know social media can have a
positive impact on society by spreading
important productive
information
but when you get total
untruths and quietly quite frankly lies
and absolute crazy distortions of
reality
that get picked up spread through the
social media and then certain elements
in our own political system utilize that
to distort reality and it just compounds
the divisiveness in the country when you
talk about elements in the political
society i mean obviously i was looking
back at your time and and what was said
certainly under the previous president
president trump and reminding myself of
the time he suggested injecting
disinfectant to clean covid out of the
body
are you relieved you don't have
president trump in that position anymore
back then it made it very uncomfortable
for me because in order to
maintain my own integrity
as well as to fulfill my responsibility
to the american public
i had to frankly disagree publicly
with the president of the united states
and that is a very difficult thing to do
i did not enjoy that
but that created
a backlash against me
by people who were staunchly loyal
to the president can i ask about the uh
america whether it's the u.s whether
it's out of the pandemic phase of covet
where are you at with that well you know
i i think that leads to confusion
because understandably you would not
expect
the general public to to appreciate all
the different nuances if you talk about
the explosive phase of a pandemic where
you have no countermeasures you have no
vaccines you have no drugs i mean
thankfully
the number of deaths and
hospitalizations
as a ratio compared to the number of
cases is much lower we're having
considerable number of cases now
in the u.s as we get new and new
more variants as they evolve
the deaths are still at a high level 300
a day
but it's not the 3 000 a day
that we were having several months ago
so you know everything is relative are
we still in a pandemic absolutely we are
are we in that very fulminant stage that
we were in
last year no and hopefully
the more people they get vaccinated and
boosted and the more people to realize
the importance
of when you have a high level of viral
dynamics
that when you're in an indoor setting
you should wear a mask even though
the whole world including the united
states and the uk
are just worn out and tired
by this outbreak it isn't over yet
people need to realize
it is never going to go back to zero
that's not the nature of this virus what
what do you make of those who talk about
the fact that now the media aren't doing
those daily counts and it isn't being
covered if you like in the same way
that you know
uh it it's not as bad as it was never as
bad as it seemed if you see what you
mean it so that's not about people who
are conspiracy theorists i'm talking
about those who say it was it was hyped
and being hyped and fear was being
stoked by having that level of coverage
well well first of all to say it was
hyped is just completely contradicted
by the terrible burden that the entire
world including the uk and certainly the
united states
we have over one million deaths
in the united states from this outbreak
that's not hype
that's very painful stark
reality
so anybody says that that this has been
hyped up is just not looking at what's
going on
in the world and certainly not in the
united states and and the other part of
this part of covid is long covered as
well people living with the effects of
it and i wondered dr farcher what was
your take on that how you would actually
define it because there's uh debates
going on about how it should be treated
as a physical issue a psychological
issue as both what would you say
well certainly it's a real phenomenon i
mean there's always psychological stress
associated with disease but i think if
you put that aside for a moment
the idea that there's a certain
percentage of people and it really
varies you know from a few percent five
percent up to 20 or more percent
of individuals
who when they get covid
and apparently recover from the acute
phase of it and they are no longer
viral positive if you want to use that
terminology
that they have the lingering
of symptoms that are not fully
explainable by any
yet identifiable pathogenic process
we're working very hard to try and
figure out what it is but the symptom
complex
has some degree of consistency
the most dominating one is profound
fatigue upon minimal exertion something
that would not
fatigue you at all in your prior
pre-covet condition
people are totally exhausted
sometimes they have very strange things
like sleep disturbances
like the
dysregulation of body temperatures
and some of them have a very strange
unexplainable difficulty in focusing or
concentrating which is referred to
as brain fog well it sounds hellish it
sounds awful
oh it is it is and it's real and that's
one of the reasons
why we're concerned about that and why
we're investigating it so intensively so
long covet is something
we need to take seriously until we find
out exactly what it is and quite frankly
you have to be perfectly honest to admit
it is unclear exactly what the mechanism
of this particular condition is
if i may just take you to
to another area of concern at the moment
while i have some time with you there is
a lot of concern about monkey pox
and i wonder what your level of worry
about that is with regards to to america
or what you can say about the the
current thinking on monkey parks
well i mean obviously in in a world a
global community that's been beset
with covid
for two and a half years
and you have yet again another disease
that is now afflicting people
you've got to make sure that a you don't
underplay it and just brush it aside
nor create panic
there are some significant differences
here
because we've known about monkey pox for
a very long period of time it's been
endemic
in certain countries particularly in
central and west africa
for some time
by introducing it
into the human population in non-endemic
areas and it looks like at least from an
epidemiological standpoint that there's
a heavy predominance
among the gay community gay men men who
have sex with men because
of the close personal
contact
that one has it's not necessarily in the
true sense and we don't know that but
it's not necessarily in the true sense
sexually transmitted but it appears to
be transmitted among sexual partners
in the gay uh men who have sex with men
i mean the the un aids agency said at
the end of may that monkey pox regarding
monkey pox racist and homophobic
rhetoric
risks stigmatizing the disease and
undermining the response dr farci of
course you built your career during the
aids crisis uh you'll be very familiar
with with the risk around stigmatization
and of course lessons being learned from
kovid we hope what is your concern or
response to that
well i absolutely believe we've got to
put aside stigma this
there should be no stigmatization
associated with any subgroup of a
population that has a disease
so we've got to strike
the delicate balance of making sure the
people who we see with the evidence
appear to be those
if you look at a group of 20 15 people
the majority of them at least in the
united states are men who have sex with
men that should not be a stigmatization
but that should be a clue to help us to
figure out what's going on right now so
we've got to balance doing the right
thing
to alert the appropriate populations and
subgroups at the same time as we don't
stigmatize them because stigma is the
enemy of good public health practices
we've got to stay away from that and do
what's right for people who are at risk
for this infection i suppose it's just
again in the era of social media and how
people like yourself public officials
like you can try and get through when we
talked about that atmosphere
that information lives in now
yeah i mean the social media again is
something that as
i've said so many times in other
settings
there's a good
positive aspect of it that you can get
good information circulated rapidly and
widely but it is also a great danger
when you get things that are put into
the social media sphere
and you wind up spreading not only
stigma and prejudice but also
counterproductive information so we've
got to be very careful would you say
social media companies having allowed
that to happen in certain instances pose
a public health
issue you know
i get asked that question often i i am
not
a very well tuned into what can and
cannot be done in regulating
disinformation and misinformation that's
not my lane and i've learned now after
many years of experience don't make
proclamations in areas that are not
my area of expertise so i'm not sure
what the best way to control
that there is one productive way
to do it is to try and counter
misinformation and disinformation
by getting out there and proactively
putting out correct
scientifically based and sound
correct information well i mean i'm also
just minded to bring up the fact that
you've called gun violence in america a
public health issue of course the debate
about that rages both off and online as
well
and i i wonder is that cutting through
do you think it is finally cutting
through in any way in america can you
see the political divide closing anytime
soon
the political divide closing uh no i i
see as we approach
a very important election in the united
states that the political divide is
going to get even more intense
you know one would hope and i do hope as
a physician a scientist and a public
health official
that when you're facing a common enemy
that that's the time for a country to
pull together
you know the way you pulled together
after the anthrax attack on our country
the way you pulled together after a
natural disaster
the way the uk pulled together during
world war ii and the way we ourselves
pull together
during conflicts but unfortunately we're
not seeing that we're seeing just the
opposite we're seeing
what should be something that brings a
nation together
is something that's actually
unfortunately and paradoxically
having the opposite effect of splitting
us up even more the other uh disease as
it were was fouchy fever i'm told that
swept the country
what what your face has been i've been
told also on things like donuts all
sorts what what's the weirdest thing
you've seen your face on and have you
have you been bought any of the
merchandise
no i have not i've been given
i've been given some of the merchandise
i certainly have not
bought it have you got you got a mug
t-shirt well you know these candles that
come out are kind of the more more
extraordinary i mean i can't imagine i
have my face on a candle that that
that's that's really way out there
that's way out and brad pitt apparently
played you on saturday night live yeah i
know it's
you know
most people don't really appreciate that
i i can't really pay attention to that
because i cannot be distracted
no i know
that's a pretty good one right well you
know i i said that off hand jokingly
when a reporter asked me
he he said would you like to have ben
stiller or
brad pitt play you and of course i said
brad pitt you know
everybody who's a male wishes they look
like bread pit
which i certainly don't well dr pouch we
we watched it so you didn't have to you
know you were you were too busy trying
to get that information across thank you
very much for sparing the time today
it's been good to talk to you my
pleasure good to be with you thank you
for having me and thank you for being
with us to uh until we meet again take
care and goodbye
[Music]